I've been involved in infectious disease
anthropology for over 25 years now and
throughout all of that work really I
think the the question that continues to
inspire me and to motivate me is how do
particular cultural categories of
motherhood of childhood of womanhood of
gender sexuality of difference
how are those categories connected to
life in the context of a particular
epidemic and that speaks not only to the
genesis of that epidemic but also how
that epidemic unfolds in real people's
lives every single day and where I work
in Saskatchewan the primary means of
transmission of HIV is through
heterosexual contact and through
injection drug use so again it's a very
different epidemiological profile than
that which unfolds elsewhere now of
course in pre-colonial times and in
indigenous communities that were less
affected by colonialism for four more
years than others you see indigenous
motherhood being the site of tremendous
power of great reverence but it was
colonialism that that disrupted that I
think that you know colonialism was
driven right from the 17th century on
where colonialism was driven driven by
an ethos of Empire expansion and by an
ethos of a requirement for homogeneity
and perspective and in population so we
see here of course the seeds of white
supremacy of virulent racism of
a sense of entitlement often justified
through all kinds of doctrines and and
that ethos perpetuates itself there are
of course counter forces to that there
are forces for pluralism there are
forces for diversity equity rights all
of these kinds of initiatives have also
developed so it has not been colonialism
for the wind but it certainly has been
and is an ongoing fight that's why I'm
particularly proud of the work that
anthropologists in Canada do towards
decolonization for its moving away from
that singular ethos yeah someone's
opinion may contradict yours where's my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we if what is the
nature of this reality
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on we're on-site
at the American Anthropological
Association Annual Meeting in Vancouver
British Columbia this is our second
partnership with them we are now going
to be talking about medical anthropology
and much more we have dr. Pamela down
joining us on the show hi Pam hi thank
you very much thanks for coming on the
program my pleasure I'm super excited
Pam's background is really fascinating
she's been studying infectious diseases
hiv/aids community based engagement
research motherhood maternal care
maternal health policy analysis the
cultural basis of rep rescission making
I'm really excited to get into all of
this also associate professor and
faculty member in archeology
anthropology at the University of
Saskatchewan and doing women women and
gender studies as well as transferring
now to archaeology anthropology serving
as the department head for five years at
the same time 2015 I mean this is a
great background to do medical
anthropology especially because like the
we were talking about this a little bit
earlier also with a new item this will
be interesting to hear thoughts about
this because I Douglas Cardinal brought
it up and you know his focus on like
indigeneity is yes and he goes men have
to go into the sweat lodges because they
don't have the reproductive cycle the
monthly cycle that ties it like women to
the deep force of nature and
interconnectedness and the moon and like
men don't have that so we don't I'm
actually I'm really curious to kind of
start things off with that feeling of
you know of oneness that feels like
we're this main upstream issue of our
world is that we feel separate instead
of interconnected how do you feel about
that I I think that's a very interesting
question I think that too often we posit
to interconnectedness and difference as
if they're opposite things and I think
they're in fact not I think that we find
that interconnect
and what we share is a sense of
difference it's how we mobilize and
operationalize that difference that
matters do we operationalize it in a way
that privileges our global humanity do
we operationalize it in a way that
divides us and creates divisive
categories of people where we create
thin boundaries such that we don't want
to interact when we create difference
through the establishment of thick
boundaries a blurred boundaries that's
where you get far more interconnections
and interactions so it's an interesting
question for me because I don't see it
as dichotomous I don't see divisive
difference or interconnectedness as
being either/or
I think we are both and I think in human
history we have always been both yes
it's this two sides of the same coin
yeah one is the deep interconnectedness
and the other one is this kind of like
individuality that we all get to
uniquely express our own gifts into the
world right so it's like the marriage of
those two things is paramount like kind
of like the collective
interconnectedness and also the
individual expression yep
and within that individual expression I
would say then individuals also
aggregating collectives and so then you
have obviously my own idiosyncratic
highly individual experience way of
looking at the world way of navigating
the world but that doesn't come out of a
vacuum that is in part born of my
collective identity how my community
works how I'm told my place in the
community how I claim my place in the
community so it's interesting because on
then on that one side of the coin you
get individuality individual differences
you get group differences collective
differences and then on the other hand
on the other side of the coin you get a
real sense of interconnectedness so it's
it is a constant circle where we're
moving from one level one scale to
another yes how can we best marry the
two sides of the coin I think by
continuing to talk across those
different scales or levels
so when we speak of someone's individual
experience in my research speaking about
someone's individual health experience
for example living with a long-term
chronic infectious disease when we think
about that individual experience we have
to honor that and honor those
individuals expended understandings and
behaviors but at the same time know that
there's a community that through which
those behaviors and experiences resonate
and that have in many ways enabled those
experiences so we talk about it at all
the different levels then we can also
talk about how those experiences and
behaviors are then shared by others what
are those connecting threads I think we
have to be careful with the different
ways in which we talk about it and not
reduce it or expand it only but to do
both at the same time would would it
could it be that this most upstream
issue facing in facing our society that
in many ways indigeneity holds as their
central pillar of existence their
understanding of the complete
interconnectedness that they are one
with their environments with each other
and that that first principle that they
carry is like is completely flipped on
its head in the metropolis and the
metropolis is it's not like
interconnected feeling whatsoever and
could that be then tearing like going
back caring about that
first principle about when a child is
born that they're taught that the breath
of air actually comes from phytoplankton
or trees that the bite of Apple comes
from the Sun powering it that could that
understanding be what heals so many of
the other issues I would like to think
so certainly the principle or the value
of interconnectedness the value of those
connections I think has to be manifest
and has to be woven throughout how we
raise our children how we understand our
cell
I become a little bit concerned when we
want to say that there's one indigenous
philosophy or ideas about certain things
because of course there's so many
different indigenous ideas but very
often they are in conflict with the
neoliberal philosophies that are driving
many of the major world economies and
societies today so there there is a
difference there again it's how we
mobilize or operationalize that
difference that to me is a really
important question and in relation to
human health or maternal care what would
be an optimal way to mobilize a
difference towards communing with the
one and expressing individuality at the
same time how would we mobilize that
difference optimally I think that
understanding that difference is going
to occur between individuals among
communities and between communities so
the idea would be to nourish difference
and understand it as a value great and
wonderful human things have happened
when we have cultivate cultivated
diverse perspectives when we have
engaged in that that the power of the
friction that occurs when different
perspectives come together either in
collision or in cooperation there's been
wonderful human innovation understanding
compassion human rights that come about
from that so actually enabling it I
worry that right now there's a broad
global and political discourse that
wants homogeneity in perspective and in
approach and I think that is going to
tip the scale in very very uncomfortable
ways yeah the mimetic
parallax if you will on ideas kind of
like the games of tennis that go back
and forth between people in their
dialectic of trying to progress ideas
find more multi variability find more
nuanced construct an ideal future that
way is so crucial but people have to be
in a
since trained in the art of great
conversation because otherwise cognitive
biases falling into the binary trap
there's all these different tribalism
there's all these different things that
come up that prevent people from having
great discourse and so that being
trained in knowing how to do that
like debates a really great way to do
that like a coin flip and you have to
know how to represent pro or con um and
give it a yeah exactly I tried to use
that in my classroom a lot and often
I'll ask students to take the position
that is contrary to the one that they
are most wedded to at any particular
moment because a it gives you greater
understanding of the opposing arguments
and logic and it can also be a motivator
for understanding not necessarily
empathy but understanding someone else's
collective and individual experiences
let's let's talk about what especially
on like a cultural level I'm so
interested about what is actually
happening with this this field of study
again is though what's the what's the
big word for the way that disease is
spread through a civilization epidemics
epidemics epidemiology ology that's the
study of epidemics yes exactly
okay I'm fascinated with epidemiology
because it seems as though there's some
sort of like a pattern for the
prevention again getting to what could
be like a root of even before the
epidemics happen of a disease spreading
that could prevent it from the suffering
creating suffering on so many people
what have you been seeing with epidemics
with what you're doing with the HIV and
AIDS I've been involved in infectious
disease anthropology for over 25 years
now and throughout all of that work
really I think the the question that
continues to inspire me and to motivate
me is how do particular cultural
categories of motherhood of childhood of
womanhood of gender of sexuality of
difference
how are those categories connected to
life in the context of a particular
epidemic and that speaks not only to the
genesis of that epidemic but also how
that epidemic unfolds in real people's
lives every single day and so when we
track how disease moves through around
the world and through a population for
me one of the greatest and most
important questions is what does that do
with the categories around which and
through which people organize their
lives and sometimes you see that those
categories remain completely intact
that they aren't really affected by them
but more often than not you see that
those categories explode and they become
renegotiated all of the time so
motherhood in the context of hiv/aids
completely depends on where that
epidemic is unfolding my work in in
central northern Prairie Canada shows
that motherhood is experienced very
differently whereas so many women are
concerned with the vertical spread of
HIV from the mom to the fetus or to the
infant through breastfeeding the
majority of women with HIV actually
become infected postpartum so it's not
that their children are at risk for HIV
but rather the mothers are living with
HIV and trying to navigate maternal care
with this infection so it's a different
kind of narrative than one that you've
seen a lot of epidemiological literature
especially that coming out of
sub-saharan Africa which bears the
majority of the global burden of HIV so
I'm interested in that I'm interested in
how disease unfolds in different places
and what that means for the cultural
categories around which we organize our
lives
yeah even just this perspective about a
mother
motherhood with an infectious disease
and needing to navigate that is
something that's really not mentioned
much in at least my understanding of
Epidemiology it's we don't kind of
immerse ourselves in like what it'd be
like to be a mother and have an
infectious disease it's mostly about
like prevention of infectious disease
through sexually transmitted diseases
like exactly yeah exactly
and where I work in Saskatchewan the
primary means of transmission of HIV is
through heterosexual contact and through
injection drug use so again it's a very
different epidemiological profile than
that which unfolds elsewhere and the
opioid epidemic is very much ass endemic
which is a coexisting epidemic that
where one exacerbates the other it's
where health conditions occur and rather
than simply being additive it's actually
multiplicative so that one condition
becomes ever increasingly worse with its
interaction with the other we see that
in Saskatchewan with addiction and HIV
and we see that the people most affected
or who carry the greatest burden of this
are indigenous peoples of our province
and that also then is rooted in
long-standing colonial up rootedness
racism and ongoing marginalization so
the picture becomes very very large when
you start looking at it and then you
have women navigating child care and
because they're indigenous women who
have a history of incredible
exploitation and oppression they've had
their children removed from them the
history of indigenous motherhood in
Canada is a history of child
apprehension of alienation of
degradation and the women are living
with intergenerational trauma as a
result of this many indigenous women are
very hesitant to then seek out medical
care in fear of what they view as
retribution having extra surveillance to
over their own motherhood and that's all
the colonial context
through which that governed all of that
now of course in pre-colonial times and
in indigenous communities that were less
affected by colonialism for 4 more years
than others you see indigenous
motherhood being the site of tremendous
power of great reverence but it was
colonialism that that disrupted that so
there's a whole history to colonialism
affecting indigeneity that has to do
with the way that was even at the level
of affecting the way that the mother's
children were taken from them yes walk
us through some of that the the history
of the maternal relations of indigenous
with certainly in Canada and again this
is where I work I think there's very
very parallel histories in the United
States but in Canada the Indian Act that
was established in the late 19th century
was imposed upon indigenous communities
largely because of colonial powers that
wanted to seize indigenous and
traditional lands and in doing that the
colonizing state tried to say that all
indigenous people should assimilate to
British euro society and they thought
that one of the best ways to do this was
through tremendous violence and it was
to apprehend children from indigenous
communities and forced them to attend
residential schools these were schools
that were very often located in far away
from their home communities and the
children could not speak their
indigenous language they spoke English
or French these are often church runs
schools and the children were
apprehended from those home communities
it was something that reverberates
through indigenous communities to this
day
though the last residential school was
closed in the mid-1990s we see that the
effects the psychological the social
effects of residential school
manifesting itself not only in the
former students of those schools but
also in their children as well so they
had been in the 1960s a foster care
system was expanding in Canada and again
what's known as the 60 scoop where
indigenous children were removed from
indigenous families and put up for
adoption many of them adopted throughout
the world and they lost contact with
their home communities indigenous author
Maria Campbell calls at the time of the
black car so those in the indigenous
communities would know that the Indian
Affairs agent as they were known at the
time would come in in a black car and
take children away fast forward to 20
2008 to 2013 when I did my research with
in partnership with Aid Saskatoon in
Saskatchewan and the women have mothers
and grandmothers who lived through this
history and they do not want to seek out
health resources because they say I fear
and fear is huge in these communities
they fear that the surveillance will
continue and their children will be
taken from them yeah the
intergenerational trauma that can happen
from an apprehension of a child and from
colonization and also true it's almost
as the what is the force that is being
why is that force why is why is
colonialization being the force coming
through that trying to like apprehended
away like why why does it want it like
indoctrinate into its own system
versus enabling a you know a pluralism
and then causing all the downstream
issues we're now over maternal health it
feels like they can't go and partake
right I think that you know colonialism
was driven right from the 17th century
onward colonialism was driven driven by
an ethos of Empire expansion and by an
ethos of a requirement for homogeneity
and perspective and in population so we
see here of course the seeds of white
supremacy of virulent racism of a sense
of entitlement often justified through
all kinds of doctrines and and that
ethos perpetuates itself there are of
course counter forces to that there are
forces for pluralism there are forces
for diversity equity rights all of these
kinds of initiatives have also developed
so it has not been colonialism for the
wind but it certainly has been and is an
ongoing fight that's why I'm
particularly proud of the work that
anthropologists in Canada do towards
decolonization towards moving away from
that singular ethos yeah yeah it was
actually really interesting your role
it's the cast the Casca maybe an
anthropology Society yeah
Canadian anthropology Society what is
the last CA um because we're a bilingual
country and a bilingual organization
then it's the Society for Canadian
anthropology in French so it's yeah okay
oh I see Casca oh I see I see how that
works okay cool cool okay and then and
then you are one of the thirst three
total like cool coal in in Casca itself
we have three presidential positions the
incoming president currently that's Mary
Ellen Mulholland we have a current
president that's Sabrina Doyle
and then I past present that's me and so
when the collaboration between the
American Anthropological Association and
the Canadian anthropology Society began
for this conference here in Vancouver I
was the president of Casca and so I
serve as co-chair of the program's
committee along with the former Casca
president Martha radicchio and Nicole
Peterson from the triple-a excellent
okay so that's the breakdown got it and
then is that also two-year as well for
you guys two years so you were in for
two years no arts is only one year terms
so you do one year as incoming president
one year as president one years past
president
so my year as past president will come
to an end in May okay yes and then so
now I'm you know this is probably like
one of the newest things for me that I
got to experience being here with you
guys in Canada is that when you have you
had you had an intro with an indigenous
elder from the Salish he's from the
Musquin and musk wings one of the yes
siliceous okay and and it was so
interesting just because he as well as
many of the other leaders that go up on
the stage they basically begin
everything they say with we are on the
unseeded territories which i think is
very fascinating because it would be
like you know if the cold like we were
just discussing when the colonization
comes and then the indigenous people
just completely decline and do not want
to partake just please just have the
pluralism happen if you want but don't
you know take our life ways away yes yes
and that now that it did literally
happen and that the colonization is
right here in the British Columbia coast
and throughout all these other places in
the US and around the world you start
with that phrase to remind so it's like
the ethos you were talking about at
least there is a way to bring about it
would be like if you like started
a presentation with with wanting to
mention to people about like the
interconnectedness of all in though in
the unity instead of just jump into the
presentation you start the presentation
by reminding people about how one we
actually are and so I like starting the
presentations by saying we're on the
unseated territories it reminds us that
that there is a there's colonization
that happened on the land that we're on
now yes exactly I think that land
acknowledgments are incredibly important
because it fosters or intends to foster
a sense of cultural humility that we are
not there is no entitlement here among
in settler Canada that we should be here
but rather we are here and it is as a
result of being welcomed by in this case
a representative of the Musqueam nation
who was also authorized to speak on
behalf of the slave Oh tooth and the
Squamish nations as well so hopefully it
fosters that sense of cultural humility
that is desperately needed in the world
and you called it a land land
acknowledge acknowledge meant that's so
interesting a land acknowledgement
fostering cultural humility yeah I like
that a lot yeah it's actually super
insightful I would actually recommend
those viewing to a wreck like go and
dive into the the context of the land
that you're currently on and the
indigenous annuity of that land and then
try and figure out as back as far back
as you can go who were the initial
habitants of that land and then try and
do something at an event one of the
local events that we are on the on ceded
territories of trying to invite someone
from Paris absolutely and and welcome
you to the territory and establish a a
plane for dialogue and to reaffirm our
relationships with each other yeah
that's again it's just such a fresh
unique thing that
it would be so interesting to see
something like that in at Corp
corporations I mean you have like we are
our org Espace and Silicon Valley and so
to know when you know the googles or the
Facebook's or all these big companies
are starting up there you know could
they say something like that could one
of the biggest companies say something
like that that where I'm not in ceded
territories here in Mountain View
California yeah yeah yeah that would be
really interesting and would be really
helpful for the further awakening and
for people I'm I'm I'm actually still
really curious about your thoughts on on
this specific thing which is um there's
a there's like a a relationship right
now between we were talking about the
one between indigeneity and kind of like
the light of the metropolis life and how
there's in a sense there's like and
that's like modernity and then the in
indigeneity and there needs to be some
sort of a a understanding of the first
principles of indigeneity in the
metropolis so that way we don't we have
a higher chance of of prosperity and not
of continuing processes that lead to
additional suffering I mean this was one
of them this idea of land
acknowledgments is at least one of them
right what are some of those other
principles and how do you think we can
bring them into modernity and like where
we're going I think that in Canada we've
had the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission looking into the effects and
ongoing traumas related to residential
schools and there are action items that
have been established by that Commission
and I think drawing on some of those
action items things such as continuing
land acknowledgments understanding why
they are used for indigenous people who
find themselves in urban environments
ensure that there is adequate and safe
transportation for them to return to
home communities
really to be thinking more about the
environmental impact of large urban
living really to be respecting the
environment in many ways that is the
theme of this conference is changing
climates and thinking about what it is
we do what it is we produce what it is
where what it is we're throwing out and
keeping and you know when you throw
something away it never goes away
right it could just go somewhere else
and landfill that's right to the
landfill or to indigenous lands
somewhere that have been appropriated by
state authorities to put garbage dumps
there so it really thinking beyond the
boundaries of any given urban space and
thinking more environmentally yeah
there's the seventh-generation principle
is a very interesting one of indigeneity
where you're never thinking about just
the effects on your own decisions on
your own lifetime but you're thinking
about its seven generation yeah that
gives a tremendous amounts of foresight
to like how can we actually design that
social fabric that will make it so that
when children are born that it's a most
highly conducive towards actualization
and interconnectedness and another
question that that I need to ask is that
now is a very interesting time between
the yin and yang of them male and female
and it's as though that remembering our
roles with each other in the most loving
and compassionate and harmonic way
possible is the only way that is the
best way and at times it feels like we
get became disconnected and separate
from that there are incredible aspects
of
of a female intuition with with nurture
and of and of gestation of a child and
like which men obviously have no idea
they don't go through that and then you
know men have no creativity in building
and they want to go and tinker and make
things and so there's like this
beautiful I think marriage and I'm
curious of your thoughts about you know
the current state of the of where that
is that harmonic love and how we can
make it where we want it to be I I
certainly think there is balance and in
many indigenous philosophies there's a
balance between feminine and masculine
sometimes the metaphor of an eagle or
two eagle's wings is used for that to
give flight and sustenance and purpose
to to the bird I shy away from making
stereotypes about masculine and the and
femininity there are women who are
strong and build things and go into
combat and do that and there are men who
are incredibly nurturing there are
transgender men who carry children there
so I think we there should be care taken
when we're talking about about that I
think that we might want to redirect the
conversation to think about gender not
again as a binary between masculine and
feminine but something that is a huge
continuum and what values are situated
along that continuum
how is nurturance exhibited for example
when I talk about motherhood among the
indigenous women affected by hiv/aids in
Saskatchewan I thought this would be a
study of motherhood and it's amazing how
many men said well what about us we care
for our children let's talk about
fatherhood right along with that let's
talk about Parenthood and so the project
then actually expanded to be something
about the value of nurturance and of
care and how gender situates itself in
all kinds of ways throughout that value
yeah like that so
it may be that a majority fit into this
classic yen and young and then there is
a lot of other variation that is that
has also beautiful values that can then
be understood and brought into our
perspective and how we can kind of
harmonize the different values that we
have on nurturer and on building and all
these different ways across I also
really like the two wings decide that's
really nice as well it's as though and I
mean in a sense the United States and
China being to the largest most
flourishing by metrics let's say of GDP
and stuff the economies of the planet
also in in a sense a need needing to act
like wings on a bird and working
together to ensure harmony peace
prosperity for all and not monkey
politics yeah this is another one of
those big ones like minimum women in
China in the United States it seems like
actually there's there's ridiculous
monies we talked about at the very
beginning that interconnectedness and
the individualism there's like just two
sides that you know sometimes it's like
flying one yeah there certainly are
imbalances there for sure and and I
think again maybe a one way to think of
it it would be something like a like a
sphere of some kind so that we're seeing
how things interact and and connect with
one or the other rather than it really
being that sort of one side or another
side I'm just trying to think of
different metaphors we can use to think
about how forces and multiplicity can be
represented in ways outside of a a or B
coin yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
interest i like the sphere you know
there's yeah yeah yeah and it may work
in me
for ones like interconnectedness and
individualism it may work there's those
are pretty guess more clear in ways then
it maybe not so clear I think it's messy
I think an anthropologist job is to see
complexity yeah yeah and so when you say
individual we can ask well what do you
mean by that do you mean you know you as
an individual or Pam as an individual or
do you mean an individual community it's
hard to think of oneself without
thinking of the people with whom we
relate every day so the layers to
there's layers to that and even within
how do we connect even with other
individuals and non-human individuals so
there's a notion of our interconnection
with all of the animals with the
microorganisms with the plants so I mean
we could reduce it down to the singular
cell but even there I think a cellular
biologist would say I can see I can see
the effects of a broader environment on
this one individual cell so even there I
see complexities on that individual side
of the coin all the way from the Planck
volume to the universe yeah I see I see
in humans in the middle that's right
yeah yeah yes this is this is another
really good way of visualizing it is the
taking it more as like this sphere and
looking at the layers of complexity on
these sides that were they were talking
about they may have so much of like our
maybe most first principled
understandings but then it is also just
so it's like it - it's just always
trying to figure out what is an optimal
path forward and
[Music]
bringing it just seems like it's it just
seems like it is that one where it feels
like indigeneity has so many first
principles that have been choked out by
the economic machinery and I and it just
seems much more in favor to moving
forward to bring a ridiculous amount of
the indigenous wisdoms and principles
into modernity than it is to also there
are I guess good aspects to modernity
that yeah like we wouldn't necessarily
be able to if you you know broke a bone
Western medicines excellent
yeah Western medicine is very good at
that broken bones at infectious disease
many infectious diseases you know I
lived through dengue fever as a thank
you Western medicine for for getting me
through dengue fever when I was doing my
doctoral research so it's it's it's very
good at many things but in terms of bone
setting I would easily go to an
indigenous healer as quickly as I would
go to go to a Western medicine
practitioner as well yeah yeah they
should actually physically setting
broken bones yeah yeah actually we with
the archaeological evidences is really
fairly strong and ethno medical
residence is strong that there's a huge
wonderful understanding of human biology
and medical treatment I'd say Western
medicine probably has an edge and some
in curing things like cancer and again
cancer is not one thing it's many things
there in terms of antiretroviral
medications things like that but in a
lot of things
the indigenous healers are far advanced
I'd say than some Western practitioners
totally and that was a really
interesting one because most people go
broken bones Western medicines yeah I
mean you think about it like millions of
years of
human prior to Western medicine how did
if break happened there had to be a
process of figuring out how to you
wouldn't just let it you know hanging
like you would figure out how to set it
in the way that felt at least the least
painful that's right and then maybe
create some sort of like a wrap and and
hold it there for several weeks and not
exert pressure so then maybe after those
months it would feel like it was at
least somewhat oh absolutely and and
people of of all Heritage's have come
into contact with with human remains and
skeletons and they smart people learn
from that they learn from working with
animals you learn from all kinds of
things and pain management it seemed
there are many Asian medical systems
that have Barbet or pain management than
Western biomedicine does it just this
this the revisiting this conversation
with so many of our of our guests
recently on the program plus up Triple A
is just so important it's just it's it
comes back to the same first principle
there's lots of indigenous wisdom that
is not in modernity and that is why we
have this all these symptomatic issues
that exist and again we come back like
the marriage again of of whatever the
sphere
looks like paramount it doesn't seem
like there can be anything more
important right now than that modernity
is just it's just um
what do you think we're building
artificial intelligence and robotics for
wow that's a leap okay it's well out of
my wheelhouse but I I think that there
are many different motivations for
people to exploring different kinds of
robotic robotic advancements I think it
can be for to explore new frontiers I
mean I know that some physicists for
example are working on that in terms of
looking at different kinds of stars star
formations things like that
we need more specifically that place
even more specific would be are we
building the metropolis is to build the
artificial general intelligence as is
and the super intelligences the digital
super intelligences some what we're
building it for
and then for who for what you don't see
indigenous people building AI what's
going on well some do but I think like
some indigenous people build AI oh yeah
tell me more
oh yeah and well there are indigenous
physicists who are involved in that yeah
I mean I don't know that you know like
the you know a particular indigenous
nation would say this is now what we're
going to do but there absolutely are
indigenous scientists who who are
involved in all kinds of enterprises
including those who are working on AI or
robotics or or nuclear research yeah
interesting but yeah but yes that's
great to point out so you have a really
important plant but not at like the
scale of Google or Microsoft or Baidu or
whatever it's not happening at an
indigenous corporation like that but
dude does it think does that feel like
the goal of these metropolis is to build
this super intelligence I don't know III
really don't I do know that the history
of
technology is such that there's always
going to be advancement and the sort of
advancement in moving for the sake of
advancement moving that's an ethos that
drives us I'm not sure that there's a
goal in sight per se I think in
obviously a capitalist economy the the
ultimate goal would be for for many not
all many would be you know further
wealth greater economic achievement
greater economic proliferation of riches
right but I think there may be other
reasons and a lot of them would be what
we're doing it because we can it's the
next question that comes up it's a sense
of technological advancement for the
sake of advancement however one wants to
define that and there will be debate
around that as well just this very seems
like there's a fire and there's some
music and there are some plants and some
animals and some culture happening
around in this set aside and then
there's some people coding on quantum
computers on the other side and I'm very
interested to see where that leads again
it's a dichotomy I think we want to be
cautious with yeah yeah yeah yeah Pam
this has been a lot of fun yeah it has
thank you very much really appreciate
you coming on the program all right my
pleasure thank you very much thanks
really great work ok thank you thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear thoughts
in the comments below on the episode
listeners you're thinking check out the
links in the Bible Oh to Pam's work also
check out the links in the bio below to
the American Anthropological Association
go and support them you can support us
you can support our show so you continue
your doing cool things like coming on
site to great events like this and go
and build the future everyone and if
that's your dream since the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in we will see you soon thank you
thank you as their budget girl yeah you
did okay I don't know
[Music]